game is a great setter of pace
and if anyone can win this one it's
going to give them well a great head
start absolutely and here we go remember
best out of four rapid games if they are
tied then we will head straight into tie
breaks with blitz and armageddon and we
have three pawns on the board we do and
it's a queen's gambit it's the queen's
gambit accepted and i have a feeling
this is going to go into one of the
sharpest lines of the queen's gambit
accepted as well we see that black is a
pawn up right now and he guards that
pawn with his queen this leads to a long
forcing variation look at all the
attacks and counter attacks that are
about to happen white is threatening a
massive night jump to give a check
but black meanwhile just developing
calmly he's given his pawn back level
material now
and uh often this involves a bit of an
uh sacrifice for black black's rook in
the corner watch out for that one
disappearing if the white knight goes
and uh grabs it now this is a check
and this has been debated at the top
level quite a lot recently aronian
himself has played it i think he's even
fallen to a defeat or two um he's played
it on the white side
and uh yeah this one it's very
surprising to see aronian switch colors
and play with black now yeah and uh on
that subject you're completely right
aronian did play with the white pieces
he beat hikaru nakamura in this exact
opening with the white pieces and lenia
dominguez
and uh in the uh fide grand prix
yeah and uh actually yeah it was with
colors reverse so ronin was white but
his opening preparation in those two
games was extremely impressive if i
remember against hikaru nakamura he
played a line that wasn't the computer's
top choice
viewers were surprised uh nakamura was
surprised but he just seemed to have it
all planned out he'd predicted the
mistakes that nakamura would make so
right now if we talk about the position
black is down
a rook
for a knight and a pawn so not a huge
material
imbalance but it's more about the kings
right now white's king is in the center
about to be checked uh look at that open
file black's king stuck in the center as
well and won't castle anymore
this is one of those openings david uh
you mentioned yesterday about systems
um which we saw uh richard i think it
was just a rich report play a system
opening where each move has a like
long-term idea um like a strategy quite
an in-depth strategy positional strategy
behind it but this opening i would say
is completely the opposite this is the
opposite to what we call a system
opening this is a crash bang wallop
opening this is literally like go for it
you need to memorize your moves here
you need to have done your homework you
need to use chessable for example and
done lots of uh lots of background work
because if you do one move wrong in the
opening here and they're banging out
their moves but if you forget your move
at any moment you could just be losing
because it's so sharp there's a material
imbalance on the board and um yeah your
memory needs to be great in order to
play uh this this type of opening for
both sides
um especially for black though because
black's material down and black's king
is stuck in the center for the rest of
the game so i think the stakes are
slightly higher for aronia but as simon
says yeah you need to know your plans
you need to know your
direct moves for both sides and uh still
very interesting because they are still
following a game that was played
i think in 2021
in december between uh two players from
in budapest and i can just also see by
checking the cloud database that has
actually been heavily analyzed there's
been many people looking at this
particular position over the last year
it's really you use this cloud database
all the time ivanka since the since the
world championships and it's a great
indication it seems of uh
what the top players and their seconds
might be investigating so it's uh yeah
it's very interesting it's like being a
spy you know you'll find out all their
secret works
so yeah but it's again this they're
still moving so quickly and you know if
if anyone's wondering is this theory
still are they following stuff as ivanka
says yes 100
and they both would have
done a lot of work i think to on this
position but it's it's it's not really
general principles as much though is it
it's like
this is the modern
kind of chess that you see a lot this is
like compute what does the computer say
you know can i get away with this kind
of thing but um david i guess black's
got this
flux of pawns on the queen side which is
which is great compensation um for for
the exchange down he's got and a nice
square in the middle of the board yeah
and do you mention the square in the
middle of the board one of the knights
will try and blockade white central pawn
it's an isolated pawn after all uh but
first arjun moves again he moves his
knight out of the way
uh yeah i mean this type of opening
strategy is so risky for lev on iranian
partly as we mentioned black is
exchanged down uh that that means he is
a rook for just a night down but the
black king in the center such a target
and most of all it's a stylistic thing
arjun his biggest strength is his
opening preparation he clearly knows
what's going on here he's clearly
studied it very very deeply he's got 17
minutes on the clock now he's even
gained two minutes
and levon
whether he's still in book whether he's
still trying to you know go into the
memory banks right now it's unclear but
you can't bluff this type of position
you can't just freestyle would you play
this as black david never ever i think
uh
it's a stylistic thing it's not my style
but
even if i'd even if i'd studied this for
20 30 hours this exact position trying
to memorize even if i had all the best
notes out there
i would never dream of touching it
against someone like eric icee maybe
against a less well-prepared player yeah
sure what about you vancouver would you
give this a go or well not this exact
line i mean it's just a little bit too
wild for my liking but i did have an
incident actually quite recently where
we but myself and my opponent just
bashed out all these moves and then i
just made a terrible error you know i
just got my ideas my move order confused
and that was it i was completely lost
and that kind of thing it's not really
chess it's just a memory test
and it's unfortunate i kind of hate that
about modern day chess a bit uh probably
because my memory is not as good as
these youngsters and uh and you have to
do a lot of work right to keep up the
latest theory and you can avoid this way
of playing though i mean it's if you
don't want to play this way you can play
more positional systems uh so it's kind
of it is a stylistic um choice as david
says really what kind of style you want
to
impose on the board but this is like
yeah like you say if you play one bad
move here especially if you're black
because black's under more danger you
just lose and it's as simple as that so
but having said that the same goes for
white right if white starts making a
series of inaccuracies then maybe black
is the one that can take over in the
long term and uh well
levon retreats his dark square bishop
i reckon as soon as um maybe here arjun
slows down that's going to be like when
aronians made a mistake
because because he's probably like
looked at this with the computer and as
soon as aronia doesn't play the
computer's top move probably here david
um it's gonna it's an indication that
his speed that that he hasn't looked to
this position and maybe arron has made a
mistake that often happens right i
always breathe a sigh of relief when my
opponent starts slowing down and i think
i was like okay at least we're out of
book at least
yes
the thing is that if you like make a
serious mistake and they know about it
they're still carrying on let's say
yeah yeah no it's true i mean and in
these positions even if you make a
mistake
they're so complex you've got to you
know to take advantage of them as it's
still going to be tricky
but i don't know i mean this is so hard
to explain this position but it's uh
it's now white who has the move it's
hard to explain simon but should we try
give it a go david let's jump in i can
understand by the bar that uh arjun has
a great advantage in this game yeah it's
a great advantage but as we've been
discussing it's the type of advantage
that could just disappear in one move if
white is inaccurate maybe you'll go
we'll see the evaluation by swing to
black side
so for the first time in the game arjun
hasn't studied this position so he
didn't study this bishop retreat that
level neronian just made and this bishop
retreat it's a bit odd to me
first of all it's kind of
counterintuitive to allow your opponent
to take a bishop with their knight
because now suddenly white has the
bishop pair but aronian is arguing that
especially this bishop is not an
effective piece right now this bishop is
a bit stuck maybe it can step back at
some point but it's not going anywhere
anytime soon it's just staring against
these really strong pawns remember this
is black's kind of main advantage in the
position the potential long term of
these three pawns so that's a long-term
factor
kind of neutralizing the bishop right
now so i don't think arjun's going to
immediately capture this bishop but so
many other tempting moves you could use
this piece which is actually the bed of
white's two bishops you can bring it to
this square maybe pin the black knight
here you could possibly bring it to this
square pin this black knight
those are the first two moves that come
to my mind
you could make an argument for capturing
the black knight and kind of shattering
the black pawn structure over here these
are really weak pawns right now but on
the downside potentially you do allow
black's rook
a file towards your king later so that
one has to be weighed up carefully
there's a lot of tension
if we go back on white tonight right now
it is attacked by black's knight so i'm
thinking that arjun will either use his
bishop and create a pin or he'll or
he'll kind of move his knight
trade it off for something but uh
there's a lot of choice as we mentioned
this bishop has two very nice squares to
jump to
this knight can capture this piece this
piece you can make an argument for it
going this way to attack a pawn you can
make an argument for it maybe sitting on
a square like this one
there's quite a lot of arguments to be
made there
are so many potential moves i mean
it is a lot of fun playing these
positions when you get out of the theory
stage because they are so dynamic and
they're certainly exciting but you're
always a little bit worried i'll know
you know have i walked into some some
you know
theory some opening preparation my
opponent has prepared and uh i suppose
as you said like the danger just looking
at the position is quite easy to tell
who's under more danger and it must be
black because white's king is castled
white's got the extra exchange which
could be you know you've got more
material
and you know just king safety is is the
first thing to always consider i'd say
uh and the queens are on the board i
think black would love to get the queens
off the board right um and that's i
suppose in the ending black's queen side
pawns because that that's what he's
aiming for to try and trying to use
those guys to to queen to get another
queen uh later on but he's he it's not
he can't get the queens off the board
easily in this type of position 20 odd
moves before you can start pushing these
pawns as black so you just need to
survive the next 20 uh 20 or so moves
and uh survival is not going to be easy
you said that
the other three black pawns that they
are very weak but with the king not
being behind them yeah could it be
a couple points that you know levon can
just push forwards and
he doesn't really have to keep them down
there yeah i mean for example if white's
knight were to make a passive move and
retreat somewhere
i'm not sure exactly where then you
could see someday um you need to prepare
it but someday eventually black pushing
these pawns towards the white king
definitely because black's king is not
on that side of the board but at the
moment
yeah they lack a bit of defense and they
become weaker especially if white trades
off and uh doubles up these guys so
white can make those pawns weak but at
the same time they are potentially uh
something that uh aronia will try and
mobilize a bit later these pawns and a
cave i was going to suggest this move
but it looks uh well i mean firstly i
couldn't calculate it uh eric i see
spent his time calculating that but
secondly um it looks like it just gives
up a pawn so he's pushed this pawn
forward it wasn't isolated pawn and
aronian has just grabbed it he's just
said saying i'm calling your bluff i can
take that pawn the whole idea eric i see
uh has by giving up that pawn is that he
wants to open up lines towards the black
king without the white pawn now he's a
bit closer to breaking through on the
d-file for example he can throw his
bishop out the way now with a check
gaining a bit more time suddenly the
white queen has come to life on this
file it's all kind of hanging together
by a thread for black
i'm not sure what black's move is here
to be honest because if for example you
try and block this check with your
bishop then suddenly after night takes
night
the pawn has to recapture it's all rude
really really loose this knight is
oh it feels like it's about to drop off
instead erigaicey um slightly
surprisingly captures the bishop first
but maybe now he's going to deliver a
check
with that bishop i mean do you have to
move the king forwards yeah that looks
it's the kind of move right i just it
looks like so ugly uh but what else can
you play i mean maybe this is it yeah we
can run and hide on this square at some
point yeah but you block your bishop
like you say it's ugly we're going to
see this yeah yeah we're definitely i
really like this pawn sacrifice that um
eric icee did because when i was looking
at the position i was thinking white's
rook
in the corner not doing a job and
probably doesn't have a future but here
the queen and the rook can coordinate
and now it's just about activating the
light square bishop and once she's in
the game
well i think white is in great shape
yeah the rook's coming like you said
it's a nasty check and the white queen
of course could not go to this square
previously because there was a white
pawn there which wasn't doing much
actually because it's going to be
blockaded so now this white queen is
looking
very very active there maybe of a rook
coming behind it as well uh i mean you'd
love to get the if you're playing with
white pieces get the light square bishop
into the game i don't know how you can
do that but if you could get it to where
the white pawn is then then yeah it'd be
it'd be just all over i think um maybe
later if you get time you can push it
forward and then activate the bishop on
this diagonal somehow but you have to i
mean can you can you can you
i want to sacrifice it
i am the bishop wow
i don't know if i do but i
i want to think about sacrificing it
and and then maybe just calmly you know
just try to open up the position more
but it's a little bit a little bit over
the top probably to do this i mean it
feels like at the moment there's no
breakthrough really black will just
control the light squares and yeah the
knights at least defensively they're
okay a bit too much probably but
definitely in store for later maybe um
yeah i think just automatic just improve
the rook the worst place piece and the
attack goes on
but maybe black has a mini threat here
maybe black is threatening to play queen
into the middle trying to get those
queens off i mean i say a threat it it's
not
obviously winning it okay that's why
he's moved the bishop back maybe to just
stop this idea because black would love
to get those queens off then
and i think if black can do that maybe
black is better than if he can exchange
them off so hence why white stopped that
with his last move so yeah if the rooks
come off for example if we see a capture
of rooks at least white controls all the
lines so white has the better bishops
why has the queen the rook all the
linear pieces
black has uh the knights which are a bit
stuck just defending each other right
now so
computer says 0.0 this looks anything
but a draw it's uh still livening up
this game we do have a draw already
though the first game between the niche
gear and young christoph duda after less
than 15 minutes that one ended with a
draw they have 15 minutes break and game
two we'll start with the young
christophe duda having the white pieces
in the second game
huh that was a quick draw
very very quick yeah
surprising as well because the position
was still full of life and they found a
way to repeat the position it feels like
anish was a bit afraid maybe or
uncertain how to continue uh-huh and we
also see in the first game between weiyi
and samsevia on the bar
all the way over to wei side starting
with the white pieces
tough start to the knockout stage for
savion who ended on top in the
preliminaries and as mentioned we are
asking you guys to help us decide which
games and which matches to
keep the closest eye on today and
typically enough the day we decide to do
this twitter is having technical issues
so the poll on twitter is not really
working so that's why we have now
created a poll on instagram so head over
to the champions chess tour page on
instagram
click on the stories and you can cast
your vote there and we will pay
attention to it and um we will listen to
you and choose games according to the
matches you guys want to follow
that is uh that is true and just to add
that the retweets are still working so
if you still want to enter our
competition one year chess 24 premium
membership up for grabs then please
retweet the poll on twitter yes to be
with a chance to win hopefully twitter
will fix their issues did he don't take
over today by any chance
maybe it's his first day in the job
today
he pulled out of uh i know i think he
has pulled out being sued by twitter
being sued by twitter because he pulled
out of buying treasure correct this is
the protest yeah but maybe it's just
because he wants to play chess because
you mentioned david elon musk he keeps
tweeting about chess
constantly yeah he's obsessed yeah
but yeah we need to get him on board to
sponsor the tour oh that would be fun or
even invite him to the celebrity
tournament in miami
is this breaking news then yeah there's
gonna be some fun stuff going on during
the major in miami starting august 15th
yeah i hope to see some celebrities
there yeah it would be interesting to
see what uh the viewers want yeah
celebrities play in chess
because there are quite a few
celebrities that do play chess we've
seen will smith record a video of
himself playing chess really yeah just
don't let him get a bit upset
it's all right until he loses the game
right
don't take his queen
[Laughter]
i just meant the queens are off the
board in this game
yeah lots of celebrities yeah
i mean who would you pick then if you
could play a game of chess quite a good
uh question for twitter but if you could
play a game of chess against any
celebrity yeah who who would it be
anyone anyone think of
someone
any celebrity at all in the world
one game one game one game
can you think it's a bit putting
everyone on the spot
a little bit i'll give a bit of time to
think mike tyson plays some chess right
but i don't think i really want to play
him
simon's there during a chess game
he's really into chess actually he's an
english boxer
and
joshua he's interested he's super into
you so anthony
chess you know he he went to oxford
university to do a talk there and the
first thing he did when he stepped into
oxford is he said i want to go to the
chess club i want to play some chats
and uh he played against uh one of my
english women teammates and he lost and
she told me that he was slightly miffed
that he lost he was kind of feeling that
you know actually he was in with a
chance yeah yeah sure
good boxer as well yeah yeah a very good
boxer yeah
and meanwhile in this game the queens
are off and simon who said that would
really benefit black but
um yeah ronin
has he made a big achievement here by
getting the queens off he still has that
three versus one advantage now with the
black pawns on the queen side
does it feel like the black king's a bit
open though the white bishops the white
rooks are going to start peering at the
black king
in the near future it's really tense i
mean i just don't know who has the
advantage
uh simply it's so imbalanced and the
computer says it's roughly level
which doesn't help us at all that's just
infuriating
i quite like that move though because
he's making a a nice square for his king
right i mean
the the king didn't really want to step
in front of the bishop but
maybe with this last move he can come
behind the bishop and feel quite safe
there actually and
i think one of the issues that black's
had all
so far as we mentioned is
his king his king has been really drafty
so by putting it there you're also maybe
getting a bit nearer to supporting your
pawns but it's uh i think i think i
would take black yeah i would take black
as well and i love that king movie
suggested because it's like over
protecting every single thing and
of course the king if one can dream a
little might even be able to step
forward and support the pawns
um that would be seriously cool but for
the time being you know
i think that black should just simply
dangle the fact that you know he's got
three
potential past pawns on the left side of
the board
that's scary i mean i know i would be
panicking big time yeah number one
priority just survive just swap off
pieces and then use these three guys
later
you can bully your opponent with the
idea of any end game being good for
black
and it's level material actually now so
white has a rook for black's knight and
two pawns and the knight in two pawns
right now balance the rook but they
could be superior to the rook and i'm
really surprised by this last move i've
got to say what is the idea behind it
i don't see it i thought if anything
maybe white's bishop would want to use
this diagonal at some point but nope
this diagonal has now been blocked uh
pushing this pawn forward
really weird from eric i see maybe he
just wants to launch a pawn storm throw
this pawn forward and then this one but
mysterious very mysterious and the
evaluation part goes in black's favor
it feels like just kind of a
a visual move it's like oh my pawn i'm
throwing it forward it's in your half
now but what's
what are you actually achieving it's
unclear this pawn could be weak even
if unsupported later i think i think lev
will be very happy now um after sort of
getting through
some quite quite i mean he picked this
opening he's picked a very sharp i mean
very brave of him and it indicates to us
like he really wants to play uh with the
black pieces he could have picked
something much drier try to try to get a
draw uh do do what niche did or or dude
there but instead he's like i want to
have some fun you know i'm going to pick
a very very dangerous variation and at
this moment in time it's looking like
it's a great choice i mean i i still
think white's so absolutely okay
probably i say probably i don't actually
know i guess he's okay here but i i
think this is the kind of position you
want when you play this opening at least
on balance chances to win yeah i'm just
dreaming as black of maybe getting the
knight to a better square and then
jumping into this one or uh maybe this
square later
it just looks great for black and uh
yeah it's just about eric i see he's
really slowed down we talked about every
guy being super quick especially when
he's well prepared and he played the
first what was it 20 21 moves instantly
so he's actually spent nine minutes oh
he spent more than that because he
gained so much time he spent more than
10 minutes
on his last 10 moves
levon meanwhile back to what we know
lightning lev on uh just bang bang bang
all the moves so natural so instinctive
and they they have been flowing what
levon's been doing every piece
connecting every uh every piece defended
yeah i think and the black king as well
that wasn't castled so maybe a weakness
in the start of the game is that now a
big strength for lavon having that out
there fighting with all his pieces yeah
now the queens are off the king is
pretty safe um still some risk because
white has a couple of heavy pieces the
rooks and bishops
but uh for now the king is definitely a
valuable piece and okay it feels like
eric is just waiting maybe just keeping
his options open lifting the rook up
hinting and going after this undefended
pawn which defends the black knight so
that could be slightly annoying for
levon aronian but uh also potentially
just doubling up his rooks on the open
file
i think often in these uh double edged
positions it's like who's got the easier
play
even
even sometimes when you're a bit worse
it's like whose moves are more natural
to play and you can ask yourself that
question when you're you're playing over
the board um and it just seems to me
like blacks moves he can do a lot of
things like use this square for his
knight he can try pushing his pawns it's
easier for black to play and
there's another reason i i would
certainly pick black here it's really
interesting though because he's given up
a pawn so white's bishop can now just
grab this guy and uh what's levon's idea
there is he going to just block in this
bishop and say okay your bishop's a bit
out of play now uh it takes you a while
to kind of relocate it to a better
diagonal or is he just gonna use the
fact that the bishop's offside and
start pushing
these three now look pretty menacing
they're like the bad girls minus one
so we call them the mean girls the mean
girls mean girls but one's being taken
out yeah three musketeers i i love that
pawn construction but on the other hand
i i think it's really tempting just to
block out the dark square bishop and
force it onto a worse diagonal and then
the action begins with the pawns and you
can see our guys he said no i want none
of that and instead
moves the rook to attack some pawns
and it's
one of the things that i was looking at
in this particular position because it's
so complicated and of course there is a
material imbalance white has a work
black in return has a knight i mean how
do you make use of this rook on a1 i
mean i mean what trades does white have
to make in order to maximize the rook
pair i guess it leaves it there just to
try to deal with those pawns i mean i i
i kind of you know i like what white's
done in somewhat in some respects with
the other rook this is very clever to
create this counter play and i think
white you know one one brook's doing all
the damage leave the other rook to
defend kind of thing maybe this is what
he's trying to do and
at least he's created some counter play
and that that is the main thing right to
to to try and get some play in the
position and white white has done that
now and you know he's got a simple plan
take some pawns queen queen h-born
um it's like you said earlier simon this
position it's not about general
principles so we can't just say okay
which piece am i going to improve as
white there's no real targets it's not
clear what we're doing instead it's just
direct calculation attack
attack and just hope for the best
i think it's just that type of position
right now
black's the one who's trying to create
plans but now black has to
solve this issue with his pawns and okay
now the black bishop goes after freddie
the f-pawn
maybe white's rook is just going to jump
in take a pawn
and take this guy is lebron's idea to
try and trap this rook
okay we'll find out it's the idea to
trap this rook but no it wasn't it was
actually in this position to jump the
black knight in he's really trying to
either eliminate this bishop or push
these pawns so
it's getting really funky
i can think really funky chess
the one feeling like uh freestyling a
little bit today just uh testing arjun
here in the first game yeah yeah
definitely funky chess definitely
yeah that sounds like a word that suits
the vulneran right he's kind of a funky
he's got well he's got really funky
shirts yeah i love his funky shirts and
uh he seems like a funky guy yeah so
definitely and funky chess that must
mean entertaining chess yeah it's
entertaining chess but is it good chat
of course um he's entertaining us
clearly but levon he's not really using
that much of his time and he's made some
really committal decisions on the last
couple of moves so he has brought his
knight to the center threatening to push
those pawns now
the problem is for levon ironian is if
all of his pawns disappear on the right
half of the board then even if he gets
his other pawns rolling white at some
point can just sacrifice a piece for all
of those pawns deal with that issue and
i don't know you're just running out of
pawns you're just left with your
position in ruins yes you might win some
material long term but short term
i'm really worried about levon's chances
i would just continue grabbing pawns
with the white rook just ignore what's
going on right now
on the other flank you could make an
argument for white's dark squared bishop
just stepping away from any potential
threats
was that was a free a little fret maybe
or
potentially maybe not but this seems
like very wise doesn't it now a free is
not a threatened
at least white's got an idea he's got
passport now as well so which is nice to
see i read the h pawn yeah our favorite
pawn definitely it's not doing much
right now looks really innocent but give
it a few moves to match up the board it
promotes on a dark square which is
always the key when you have a dark
squared bishop right yeah so uh white's
h-born could be a winner later but first
level onion this was his idea all along
to lure the white bishop into his camp
and then try and trap it kind of lock it
out of the game
but it's so complex i mean it's too hard
to get out of that yeah that's the
problem it just takes two or three moves
and you're back to a good square
i still take black here i still look
because i i like something i like his
centralization you love your fun
positions it's more fun
yeah i think so i mean it's probably
it's probably bad but i i kind of
i just kind of like the way those pawns
those pawns seem like they're going to
start coming soon surely pieces in the
middle
that's got to be a good thing i mean uh
today yeah they're not easy to mobilize
though for the time being but uh i i
have to say i also quite like black's
position
even though
white does have the extra material
yeah those balls are just too scary i
mean am i threatening a free to to you
know just try to queen
okay not anymore so um we have another
move david yeah white trying to get the
rooks off makes some sense blacks rook
was maybe the supporter of any pawn
pushers on the side of the board so if
the rooks disappear
you would think that that favors
favors white but if we do see a rook
trade white bishop will be stuck in the
corner then it will take a few squares a
few turns to
kind of get back out get back into the
game i mean i think black's got to get a
past pawn here right so
let's say you take the rooks and then
you know i don't know
kings king c5 or c3 maybe just got to
get those pawns moving now it's going to
be a race isn't it queen side pawns
blacks
pawns coming down and then that that
harry porn probably coming up the board
i think it's gonna be really really
exciting the end game here yeah so yeah
white's pawn will run black's pawns may
be starting with like you said moving
the king forward and then at some point
you push this guy get rid of white's
lone ranger and then push your pawns but
okay first he actually takes the time
out to remove a pawn of whites and here
we go the race has started things are
really going to heat up over the next
few moves oh that's cool now simon you
mentioned levon's funky style and both
when it comes to his chest playing and
his funky shirts there actually is a
cool news story on the chess 24 wall
right now
about the chess olympiad so apparently
fidei has
decided to ask the players to think like
fashionista there's going to be prizes
during the olympiad for the best
dressed team what do you guys think
about that
i think that's very cool yeah i mean i
think they i think it was maybe david
you mentioned that earlier
or maybe me i don't know
we want to see a team turn up in
mankini's basically
that deserves a prize for feed surely i
mean if there's code it's encouraging
yeah creativity right and uh yeah
yeah yeah i i like it you know because
they
it's a bit stuffy when you have to wear
like a suit you might be uncomfortable i
mean i i hate wearing you know stuffy
clothes
it especially if you're trying to play a
good game of chess right so so i like
the idea it's cool but yeah it's likely
to be very very warm over there in india
as well so
yeah it's it's nice not to have to wear
a tie during the games and
um yeah maybe that'll be england's best
chance best chance for a prize
well in price well you could be leading
the way couldn't you yeah
your style actually yeah if any of the
viewers have suggestions what clothes i
could wear maybe going away from the
suits
i can think of a nice uh full body uh
thing that you've you've maybe worn
before
potentially um
or this one this was the english team
was it the previous olympia yeah it was
the previous olympia very nice those
blazers four years ago yeah they they
did very well uh our english men's team
and also the women's team also did well
um i have to admit i was the one
responsible for inflicting these
terrible jackets on them wanted us to
look like naughty
i know what happened was that there was
no well the whole idea was that those
would be dark navy and the the stripes
would be a lot thinner so i think tommy
hilfiger yeah that was that was a look
and this is what came
well actually i have to say it actually
suits the women's team better than that
what are you saying
but they did uh they did bring us luck
ever since these uh these jackets were
introduced we came fifth in the olympiad
we came second in the world team
championship week and we also got medals
at the european team championship and we
hadn't won medals before that for 21
years so they probably will we see those
in india and chennai this year maybe
unless the viewers have better ideas i
like it and will the team have to wear
the same uh kind of clothing i guess not
forced to but it's a nice touch right if
you're all combining you feel more like
a team if you're all in the similar
outfits and well with levon
in the us team i bet he's gonna ask the
other u.s players too or something funky
maybe that's gonna be interesting to see
fabiano caruana wesley so turning up in
flowery shirts
like hawaii shirts right it's a us team
oh that would be cool
let's see if we will have some funky
blazers i'm sure it's in the olympiad
and uh are we having any funky moves
yeah but potentially um this game is
going to get even weirder over the next
few moves it could still come down to
the race that we were discussing this
last move by eric geisi offering a
bishop trade
take that bishop or don't take that
bishop big question right now for levon
and i'm going to pose it to you guys as
well simon ivanka take that bishop or
leave that bishop i would say no thank
you i mean i think the light square
bishop is needed just to slow down those
white pawns i mean especially
if you take a look at the age porn you
know it's four moves away from queening
and those black knights are needed to
assist those black pawns the trio over
there on the left that's my answer yeah
yeah no calculation i i think that's why
lev it's really yeah i agree with you
just on principle that h pawn looks so
strong and i think this is why lev's
just slow down it's like a critical
moment because if you do take the bishop
it's just a race and it is just pure
calculation because you can as david's
showing take that and just start pushing
as well and uh let's say you i mean this
could be this is actually quite easy to
calculate right because there's only one
move at a time you have to envision so
david here i don't know if you want to
show but if you push that pawn on and
white pushes what on earth is going on
here i mean who someone's going to get
first but who is it because black spawns
look quite quick as well right with the
c pawn moving next or the the b pawn i
mean it's just one of those things you
can calculate and i think lev's doing a
very good job of calculating this
um he's winning here i mean it's
no idea
really yeah really sharp stuff right
but maybe black's ahead maybe black's
ahead although
i mean bishop takes for example getting
out the way of white's porn and
something like this
or even bishop takes knight there might
be oh yeah bishop takes the kill yeah
that's actually very strong and uh
suddenly white's pawn is just too far
away for the black knight to deal with
okay also two pawns versus one yeah
yeah so i mean this is the type of thing
going through levon's mind right now
he's thinking if i take the bishops off
if i trade these guys off whose pawn is
quicker my pawn or your pawn and
if you don't trade the bishops you might
have to lose a move you might have to
retreat maybe there's a knight f4 there
which is a very useful tempo gainer
actually in the main position and
potentially i don't thinking after the
king moves
trapped this is the problem okay does
that matter though like knight g3 or
something in a second
we saw a trade we did see the exchange
happen and instead of pushing um on the
last move instead of pushing the pawn as
we were just showing in that last
variation which would have been a pure
race black's knight has jumped in now i
think you're right simon um a pawn push
might well be met by a knight check and
a capture of this pawn
so maybe haste is not good here for
white but if you're not quick then this
pawn drops
oh very exciting position here i mean uh
computer thinks white's ahead in the
race but from a human point of view it's
just guesswork it's just calculation and
hoping for the best oh yeah
so it's so hard to play this position
right i mean
again it's been the whole way through
the game one mistake you lose uh i
thought it calmed down after the queen
exchange but this it hasn't it's got
it's got even more not with these
players no it's great to see him play
like this definitely and uh yeah here
it's all about like which side can
utilize their team in order to
offensive be on defensive but also be on
the defensive as well
yeah i agree with karen one very good
strategy when you're playing against the
knights is to try and restrict them
right with your pawns
and maybe maybe here you could just
restrict that check you know by pushing
the pawn and we're back to the race
again but for example knight takes pawn
this guy runs
white her black runs white runs it does
look like white's a bit quicker here
because there's nothing stopping white's
pawn whereas white's rook acts as a
stopper for black's pawn
okay similar idea he's utilized instead
of this uh he's used his rook to come
across and
okay a bit strange to use the rook
rather than a pawn but i guess his idea
is the same after knight takes pawn he's
just gonna push now his rook covers any
knight check on this square and uh yeah
eric i see ahead in the race
yeah wow
these the positions are so mind-boggling
i've been here you have i mean you kind
of need a lot more time than they have
to figure out all the intricacies you
know sit there spend 10 minutes
in just complete harmony thinking about
this and being focused and the players
just don't have that a luxury
i mean i do think here that um the
stakes are much much higher for levon
aronian because if things go wrong for
him white just makes a queen with harry
the h pawn if things go really wrong for
white however then you can just give up
your rook give up for the black uh give
up your bishop for all of the black
pawns black has two knights at the end
and two knights alone cannot give
checkmate against the king
so for example if you imagine all of the
pawns disappearing from the current
position white's rook and bishop also
disappearing is still a draw so
white has this kind of exit strategy if
he really needs like a last resort
uh i could imagine for example the white
rook giving itself up for all the black
pawns the white bishop giving itself up
and still it would be a draw so that's
why you need to know your end games and
uh i don't think we'll see two knights
versus the king because i think white
here is doing pretty well
um just start running now arjun with
that h-pawn but
it's nice to know that you do have a bit
of safety in your back pocket and uh
less than two minutes on the clock for
arjun alright guys you remember we are
asking you guys to be editor-in-chief on
the show today we want to hear from you
guys which matches you want us to pay
the closest attention to and actually
right now
young christoph duda and against aneesh
geary is the one in the lead
ironian against eric i see uh good
number two but uh that means we will
have to pay a close attention to as well
to do that against giri and they are
currently playing game two they played a
super fast draw in the first game now in
game two so hopefully we can jump to
that
after this one finishes and this one
will we see a win will we see a draw
what's gonna happen
you said it yesterday simon these the
craziest games in chess they normally go
one way another way another way one side
attacking the other side attacking but
it always seems to end in a dream yeah
why does that happen it's like yeah i
mean
forget about the computer evaluation
it's obviously gone a bit mental today
you know
it's just gonna be a draw everything
gets swapped off draw shake hands but
we're a long way away from that it's
just a really strange imbalance and well
we now see that white is fully ready to
push push the h pawn so black's got to
got to get moving as well and oh there
you go the evaluation bars finally
caught up and agrees that it's just a
dead just a dead draw boring getting on
with the next game nothing to see here i
wouldn't say where
i was going to ask about the
psychological um
impact of uh arjun's last moves because
you know we we saw he didn't push the
h-born he instead of went for a little
bit of a safer move i think of when
bishop takes porn is he feeling the
pressure you do think that maybe he's
kind of lost in that fog which tends to
happen when you do you feel the clock
ticking down
potentially
maybe he's just trying to be really
perfectionist playing really accurate
moves it feels like not pushing the pawn
he's just trying to be a bit
too sophisticated in a way i'm curious
here can we see the stockfish moves
because i'm trying to see what there
might only be one move um you think
there's only one look at the move oh
you're right what so okay
one move holds the balance
everything else gives white what could
be a potentially decisive advantage and
do you think you'll find this i would
never dream of this move we have to show
it on the board because black's best
move in the current position
is so weird this knight looks glorious
it's on a protected outpost but to put
it on this square with a check on the
edge of the board offering itself up for
the white rook as well that is the best
move the whole idea is rook takes knight
suddenly
the white rook has been deflected and
black can take the bishop and suddenly
black's knight is actually on the dream
square guarding both of the white pawns
so it's very specific here actually in
general you don't really want to trade a
night for bishop because the white pawns
will run but here the black knight is
actually on a decent outpost and i guess
yeah time for a bet oh i mean i i would
say he i mean how can you find a move
like that i mean i know aronian's a
genius
but that move that is just such a weird
move put your knight in a city square
where it could be taking i i i don't
think he can find this move no offense
to arron he's a great player but
you know
what do you reckon you think you think
he'll find this one yeah i think he's
gonna find it i mean i i didn't see it
but uh i think maybe you've got a lot of
faith in the man so david maybe we can
keep an eye on the players just in case
he plays it but i think no
i mean it's so weird knight's on the
edge of the board
we're taught when we're young don't look
at those types of moves it's also on a
protected square automatically
subconsciously in the head we rule out
kind of putting pieces on squares where
they can just be captured
the only way he can find this is process
of elimination it's looking at the black
pawn moves figuring out those are too
slow
looking at other night moves figuring
out those don't do anything 40 40
seconds left as well maybe with maybe
with 30 minutes on his clock i think
he'd find it but i mean one minute if he
finds this move it'll be incredible i
mean i really hope he finds it but
no he doesn't oh well there you go
and uh looks like white might well be
winning now white is ahead in the race
it's pawn push now
there we go it's all about alice the a
pawn against harry the h pawn and harry
has a clear run through to goal note how
alice the a-pawn is protected
it's promotion square is protected twice
so uh
yeah just one shot one five seconds for
lavon as well clock is oh now he sees it
but there's one move too late oh that's
really sad right because
if you'd have played it last week on his
radar but why is it not a good move
anymore i've got no idea that's a good
question
absolutely if i were to say it's because
the white pawn and the h pawn has
stepped up to the fifth row so before
the knight sitting on f6 would have
stopped both pawns as it is is only
gonna stop one uh-huh big question as
well
does white have to take this knight
maybe we can see the stockfish moves
again should white take this knight or
not because if you take this knight
then the white bishop would have dropped
he doesn't take the night is that a good
move is that a good decision now the
black knight's re-rooted
this is still a race i mean it looks
like black is going to get there first
but i think arjun has a trick up his
sleeve white's bishop as well is so
strong no no how white's bishop covers
the promotion square for black and if
black wants to go and remove the white
bishop by trading it off white will
recapture with a check
so
honey continue pushing here arjun
whoever queens first is going to protect
the queening square of the opponent's
pawn that's the trick with rooks pawns
when one side's pushing overexpo on the
other side whoever queens first protects
the corner square so
it looks like white according to the
evaluation bar but
is there a trick now for ironian i'm so
happy we picked this game
out of all the game i mean look at this
one square from queening both sides both
of them both of them both of them and
ten seconds for lavon
it's difficult anyway i don't think he's
gonna find a saving move here is it what
can he play is there any way you can
keep the game going even
just take that bishop and hope yeah okay
he moves his king but the problem is
look at this it is a check and now white
makes a queen defending the corner
square and
miraculously both sides made queens and
the queens both disappeared immediately
wow i mean it's so rare to see that and
now it's all about another race white's
porn
is running but black's pawns are surely
going to be too slow now they are way
too slow uh it's going to stop them the
white pawn just has that free run you
know it's going to be unchallenged until
the very end that's totally hopeless for
lavon aronian i think he loses by just
one move as well and his king is just
too far away
aronian i mean if if he resigns we will
show why there's a really nice variation
in the air right now if black pushes his
pawns
but uh yeah no way to save this game
anymore great great play from arjun and
also ronian you know he missed a couple
of moves but you can see him shaking his
head now he he's
he's realizing that
he's a little bit slow here yeah it's
gonna be a bit careful i mean if you
push the pawn now for example
yeah black has a massive threat you have
to stop the black pawn coming down one
more square so you can do that by i
guess stepping your king across one
square you can bring your rook to the
second rank
maybe
you could also step your king forward
one square potentially just so the white
rook will come down and block on the
first rank there's a few moves
or maybe we can see the stockfish
evaluations again because
how narrow is the winning path for white
there are three winning moves at least
maybe more he is winning
so is the rook move maybe a mistake or
is it going to be
which the rick mook moving to the second
row
wow
okay
he's done it but okay so why would this
be a mistake it looks no it looks
completely winning right because
when black tries to push
charlie the sea pawn the king will step
across and we're seeing it look how the
white king and rook are completely
stopping the black pawns and we'll see a
really nice finish here after rook takes
pawn and the black knight is trapped
white's pawn runs through and wins and
he's smiling lovely smile
it's uh over what a start for our
generic icy the 18 year old takes the
lead in the match against the great
lavon or